germany says 10 eu governments including
berlin are preparing to take in
400 accompanied unaccompanied youngsters
left homeless after tuesday's fire at
the moria refugee camp
on the greek island of lesbos german
interior ministers jose hopa said around
150 of them would be brought to germany
and france but that
details were still being worked out with
the other eu nations involved
greece has provided a ferry to house
some of the 12
000 displaced refugees two more ships
will be sent
in the coming days for the past three
nights most have slept
in the open and are struggling to get
food and water
a third night in the open the parking
lot of a supermarket
people who thought they had nothing left
to lose have lost what little remained
some bear the injuries sustained in
trying to rescue their meager
possessions from the flames
and now autumn is coming and the nights
are getting colder
after sunny but not very cold
as bad as conditions were inside the
cramped refugee compound
the situation for the 13 000 former
residents of moria
is now even worse
this cannot be our final destination
like we cannot be sleeping
under this place like this you know it's
not human it's not human
400 miners have been evacuated to the
mainland
some of them may find a new home in
germany
at the same time i asked the greek prime
minister how we can help
and his request is that we in particular
take the miners and who have now been
brought
to the greek mainland we have contacted
france
and we will work together on this i hope
that some other eu states
will do this also
a passenger ferry has been pressed into
service as temporary accommodation
while the united nations rushes tents
and sleeping bags to the island
the emergency aid should arrive later on
friday
[Music]
dw's alexander fran nahman is on the
island of lesbos near the site of that
maurya refugee camp
alexander what is the situation there
now
well the situation hasn't changed much i
have to say
people thousands of them are still
stranded here just
look around among them many families the
kids are crying they
spend a third night here on the roadside
many of them
seem to be traumatized tired irritated
i spoke with a pregnant woman who told
me that she is about
to have her baby anytime now and of
course she is terrified that
that could happen here on the street i
also spoke to a mother
her child is just three weeks old
and she is sleeping and a tent that was
given to her by
an ngo so you see the the situation
is just unbearable for those families
stranded still stranded here many of
them told me
that they don't understand why it's
taking so long to resettle them they
told me we are here in the european
union we always thought that the
european union shows
solidarity it is a rich region
and we just don't understand what it's
taking so long
what are local authorities doing there
to try to house and feed
the people alexandra
so what we mainly saw here were ngos
distributing water
and food but there is at least once a
day
food distribution by local authorities i
also saw
policemen giving sandwiches away to
a children the greek authorities
promised the people here
to provide them with housing as quickly
as
possible but we also know that any plans
to to
build any temporary settlements are met
with
a lot of resistance and and opposition
from local
authorities and from local residents
here
who also say this is unbearable this
refugees these refugees from their
perspective
needs to to leave the island so
this is a very tough very difficult
situation for both for the refugees
and of course for the local residents as
well
alexander thank you very much for that
update that was dw's alexander fundament
on the greek island of lesbos
the european union is set to unveil a
new pact on migration and asylum which
will
shape the bloc's policy in the years to
come it's hoped
it will help prevent the kind of chaos
seen in the moria refugee camp
the eu's commissioner for home affairs
has told dw news she believes all member
states will back the proposals
i spoke to commissioner ilva joe hansen
in a short while ago and i began by
asking her
why the eu up to now has failed to agree
on a common humanitarian approach
to migration i can't answer why
but i can say that this is my overall
task to present
in a few weeks a new pact on migration
and asylum and i spent a lot of time
negotiating and talking with member
states and parliament and other
stakeholders
and i do think that we can present a
holistic
proposal that can get acceptance from
all member states because it's really
necessary
both for the solidarity between member
states that we have a
solid solidarity mechanism but also with
the solidarity with these
individuals that are now what you just
saw here
living on the streets and of course that
where it's not sustainable that we can't
accept that
can you say it's not sustainable what is
happening on lesbos and the
and also the european policy on
migration in general
this new pact on migration that you're
developing how is that going to help the
people who are on lesbos right now
out on the streets desperate
the acute situation we have to handle
right now but
and that's why we are active together
with the greek authorities together with
member states i'm very happy that we
have many member states also showing
stepping up saying they are ready to
help and commission of course is ready
to help greece as we
have done for many years but i'm also
responsible for setting up a new
legislative proposal so that we will
have
a better and more so a system of more
solidarity
and more resilience and a better share
of responsibility
when it comes to migration in european
union and i'm going to do that
ms johansson thank you very much for
talking with us that was illegal
johansson the eu commissioner for home
affairs